ウッ（ ;  ; ）
ウッウッゥゥゥ
うぅううぅぅぅぅうう
こんにちは　はじめしゃちょーです
とても困ったことがありまして
まぁ見ればわかるんですけど
頑張ったんですよ
僕は頑張ったぁ
何本の…
何本のうまい棒を食ったのか
自分でもわかりません
自分でもわからないくらい食べたんです
ああぁあああぁぁぁあぁあああ…
なのにぃ
なのになくならないぃいいぃいいいぃぃ…
ああぁぁぁあああぁ
あぁあぁあぁあぁあぁ
ああああぁぁああぁぁあああぁ
うまい棒10万本買っ て
プレゼント企画もし、道歩く人には渡し、家の中ではバカみたいに食い
いろんなことを尽くしたんですけど
いや…
まじでやばいです
結構笑えないやつです
この部屋に結構入れてみたんですけども
天井に届くくらいのうまい棒をバーっと並べたんですけども
全部でこれの4、5倍はあると思ってください
お願いします
大体全部同じ日に造られてて
賞味期限が大体
までなんすよ
あと2ヶ月ちょい
あと2ヵ月ちょいしかないんですよ
って思った時にもう僕はこうするしかないと思いました
画面の皆さん
皆さんに
もうそれしかないんだ
行います
ます
僕はただ…
うまい棒で
みんなの笑顔を見たい
その一心です
本当の10万本の感覚がなくてもう
どんだけ食ったことか
教えたい皆さんに
本当にうまい棒、食っても食っても食っても食っても食っても食っても食っても食っても食っても減らなくて
いろんな人に配り実家には送り
いろんな人に食べてもらったんすけど
一向に減る予定がなく
このままだと本当にやばいと思ったので
イベントにさせていただきます
本当に多分ビビるぐらいあるんで
画面の皆さんには是非ともうまい棒をタダで大量入手していただきたい
皆さんたくさん持ち帰ってってくださいね
というわけで詳細を発表いたします
本当にうまい棒を配布するためだけのイベントでございます
僕はステージに立ってもできることがありません
内容なんですけどもなんですけども
一応
の祝日に行います
で、もう場所をね決めてるんですよ
でっかい場所を借りてるんですけども
さすがに人が来すぎるとやっぱ迷惑になっちゃうんで
一応ですね応募という形を取らせていただきます
すいません手間なんですけど
ただ応募も無料です全部無料です
たくさん食べてってくださいお願いします
完全無料なんですけど一応人数の把握と
多すぎると制限もかけたいので
一応募集という形になっていますが
実質もう全員プレゼントみたいなとこではあります
うまい棒がなくならない限りは
僕がもううまい棒を直接渡しますから
応募の方法は下にありますが
もう本当に人数だけ把握したいんすよね
是非来てください
どうか
うまい棒たちを助けてやってください
でも僕がここでちょっと気になってるとこあるんですけども
すっげー たくさん渡すんで怖いんすよね
決まった数渡さないから
このイベントでうまい棒が余るかもしれないし
足りなくなるかも知れません
すいませんそればかりはちょっと本当にどうしようもないんで
すごい数準備するんですけども
すいません
余った時が本当に怖いです
もうどうしようかなと思っています
人数制限とか把握するんですけども
それでも配りきれなかった時は
どうしようかなぁ
その場でゲリラで配っちゃっ
ゲフッ　ゲフン　うっ
はいというわけでいやｗ10万本すごいっす
それで皆に配れるんだったら
まぁ僕はまぁ良かったのかなとも思います
というわけで是非みなさん
うまい棒を…
助けてやってください
よろしくお願いします
【はじめしゃちょーエンディング】